[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Daniel gal Ron and I'm an
applied research scientist at eBay's New
York City office where my team focuses
on building recommender systems so in
this talk I'm not really going to go
over frameworks I'm not going to go over
specific technologies that we use
instead I'm just going to talk about the
process by which we went about building
a deep learning based recommender system
that can scale to our production needs
so we're going to go over a lot of
material in this talk and I'm going to
gloss over a lot of detail I'm happy to
dive into the details in the office
hours following this talk so deep
learning is quickly becoming a vital
tool in every data scientist toolbox
over the last five years there have been
groundbreaking improvements in
applications like computer vision and
natural language processing and other
you know signal processing applications
in information retrieval so given the
importance of deep learning there's
unfortunately been very limited
information [ __ ] on like shared on how
to actually bring deep learning systems
to production scale problems so in this
talk I'm going to share about some of
the lessons that we learned in applying
deep learning to building recommender
systems at eBay so I'm first going to
talk about what problem we're trying to
solve and why actually the recommender
system problems that we have any there
among some of the most difficult ones in
the industry I'll then give a very brief
high-level introduction to deep learning
and talk about some guidelines as to one
it might be an appropriate tool to apply
to a problem I'll then go into how to
frame your problem as one that can be
solved using deep learning techniques
and then some of the design decisions
that we had to make in order to make the
the model that we build production
performance and finally I'll briefly
talk about how to evaluate your models
in order to allow you to fail fast when
development so what are we trying to
solve so eBay is a marketplace that
connects buyers and sellers all over the
world
I'm sure
how many of you have a accounts cool
what I would expect so at any given time
we have about a billion items that are
live on site and we have 150 million
buyers and sellers so because of our
marketplace and we don't actually hold
our own inventory we have some
interesting constraints on our listings
so first we have very limited structured
data so for each item that we have
listed there's always going to be a
title and an image and a category for
that item sometimes but not always we're
going to have some key value properties
of an item like its brand its model its
color and so on and then for some
fraction of our inventory we can map the
items to a product catalog
however by impression a lot of the
inventory we have has gaps in the
structured data coverage we also have a
very volatile inventory so oftentimes
items are only going to stay on site for
less than a week because just they
happen to be bought very quickly which
means that each item will get on average
a very small number of clicks
furthermore a lot of our listings are
single quantity meaning that only one
person can buy that item besides that
our inventory is volatile means that we
have very very sparse behavioral signals
on which we can build predictive models
and then finally we suffer from the cold
star problem because we have millions of
new items listed every day we need to be
able to provide recommendations for
those and classical techniques don't
actually help us when there's no
pre-existing information behavioral
information about an item so any
recommender system that we build has to
account for these challenges it needs to
be performed enough to provide
recommendations for a billion items it
needs to be robust enough to learn from
extremely sparse signals and it needs to
be applicable to newly listed items for
which we have no behavioral signals yet
so the standard approach to building
recommender systems is called
collaborative filtering now there are
many flavors of collaborative filtering
algorithms the one that we're going to
focus on today is called item to item
collaborative filtering the idea behind
item to item collaborative filtering is
to consider all people who have
interacted with a seed item so for
example the ratings that users assign to
a movie and then find a set of items
that have the most similar ratings
pattern to that seed item that way for
example if someone rated a movie highly
like Goodfellas this technique is going
to find movies that are also similar to
Goodfellas by considering the ratings
that the same users assigned Goodfellas
assigned to the remaining candidate
items a common way of computing this
rating similarity is by taking the
cosine similarity between the movie
between the ratings vectors of a movie
and then for a given seed item rank the
candidate movies by their cosine
similarity to the seed so to take an
example suppose that we want to find a
recommendation for Goodfellas we can
compute the cosine distance between the
ratings vector of Goodfellas and every
other movie in the data set the
calculation sort of looks as follows the
the thing to note is that sort of we're
rewarded for movies that have similar
ratings by the same user and we are
penalized according to the norms of
those vectors so like the more popular
movie is the more will be penalized now
one thing to note is that in this case
we have explicit feedback right a user's
rating of the movie oftentimes we don't
actually have that information though
we'll only have implicit feedback like
you know which users viewed an item or
which users purchased an item that would
then lead us to use um cosine distance
or cosine similarity on binary indicator
vectors so we'll get into that in a
little bit so these collaborative
filtering methods work really well on a
lot of problem domains where you can get
dense enough behavioral indicators
unfortunately in general this approach
is really really hard to apply it
eBay due to the nature of our inventory
so the fact that most of our items are
singleton items and cannot only be
bought by one person means that when we
apply cosine distance not in really
matter because there's only one user who
bought that item and so the vector
doesn't just just doesn't have enough
information um so another challenge
which we're not really going to address
in this talk is that implicit feedback
is generally less reliable than explicit
ratings right our best signals of
indicating user interest are a binary
signal such as whether a user viewed an
item or purchased an item but they're
not foolproof right just because I click
on an item doesn't actually mean that I
like it or I'm interested in buying it
now one alternative that we could maybe
use is to try to cluster listings into
static entities based on some properties
of the items and then perform entity to
entity for collaborative filtering so
this is actually what we've been doing
for a while but the problem is is that
this approach doesn't really scale in
terms of quality right because
computationally computing these closures
can be really expensive and then from
the amount of effort it takes to tune
the hyper parameters and ensure that the
clusters are granular enough to be
useful for collaborative filtering is
really really hard to do so let's
briefly just consider what information
we have about an item we have its title
we have some properties sometimes like
the brand and the color and the style um
and maybe we can you know use that
information to actually build a
predictive model that can act as a as a
recommendation model so that's what
we're going to try to do we're going to
try to build a machine learning model
that can model the common behavioral
co-occurrence patterns like Kogi's and
co purchases between items based on some
of their content features even when we
have sparse behavioral signals cool so
um that's problem we're trying to solve
let's actually go into what is deep
learning and when should we use it so in
traditional machine learning workflows
you have some input data like an image
and you as the machine learning
practitioner writes code to extract
features from this data right
so for example it might involve defining
patches of pixels using some method to
select which ones should be included as
input to the model and then training a
classifier or a regresar on these
features the problem with this is that
it requires a lot of manual effort to
define exactly the right kinds of
features that are optimized for the task
right you know you can imagine that you
have one task where you're trying to you
know predict like trying to identify you
know an animal in an image and then
another task where over the same image
you want to add no separate the
foreground from the background right
those are two different tasks and you
would actually have to you know you
actually have to manually construct
features separately for those tasks that
can be a really really expensive process
so with deep learning the idea is that
the feature extractor is just another
model right it's another function that
is parameterised and the feature
extractor can be trained end to end as
part of the system so instead of a
manual pre-processing step one way to
think about this is that the trainable
feature extractors learn a kernel from a
raw input space to a higher dimensional
space or to start a more abstract
feature space where the data is linearly
separable and it does so in an
end-to-end manner where you can have
your favorite optimization algorithm
jointly tune the parameters of the
trainable classifier and the feature
extractor in order to maximize the the
loss of the classifier typically the
Train the reasons called deep learning
is that the trainable feature extractors
are tend to be stacked right you'll
actually have um you know a couple
different extractors one on top of the
other where each extractor basically
takes the output of the previous layer
and then transforms it in some way using
its set of parameters in order to spruce
an output that again then gets passed on
to the to the classifier so for example
in the case of images you can have the
first one be an edge detector then that
feeds into a shape detector which feeds
into like an object detector and finally
that feeds into your classifier
so that's all well and good but how can
this actually help us in collaborative
filtering so you know earlier we said
that we have some information available
to us like the titles of items the
properties in the category and these can
be fairly descriptive of the functional
and stylistic semantics of the items so
at a very high level what we want to do
is we want to aggregate behavioral
signals like Co purchases across
semantically similar items so for
example if we have an item that's like a
Harry Potter collectible but it's a
singleton item meaning only one person
can buy that we want to leverage Co
purchase data from some other
semantically similar items like other
Harry Potter memorabilia to enrich our
behavioral signals so one one sort of
question though is then how do you apply
deep learning to the kinds of features
we have namely the text right so in our
case we have you know title tokens and
key value properties which we need to
encode somehow for the machine learning
algorithm to read so one common way to
do that is with one-hot representations
the idea is that we assign an integer
index to each word in the vocabulary
like the tokens that are present in item
title and we construct a binary vector
to represent them the binary vector
would have the dimensionality of the
vocabulary and would have a zero in
every position except for the index
corresponding to the token that it
represents which will have one so for
example in this 10 dimensional
vocabulary we this would be the binary
representation for dog and if we then
wanted to construct a representation for
a whole sentence you could basically
just take the element wise or of these
vectors to to get another binary vector
with 1 for every token that's in the
sentence now this is problematic right
first of all these are very high
dimensional vectors and you know what
vectors will have to lengthen the size
of the vocabulary which can be in the
hundreds of thousands if you want to
encode engrams you're going to have a
polynomial you know increasing the size
of the of your dimensionality and then
the other thing is that with these
one-hot representations there's no way
to encode you know semantic similarity
right all words are all you know
representations are equally distant from
each other
so one of the very nice innovations in
deep learning over the last few years
which allows it to be used for text data
is the development of continuous vector
representations so the idea is that each
token is going to be assigned a D
dimensional vector of parameters you can
think of these vectors as a feature
extractor where each token is associated
with D features and then the vectors are
just parameters in a neural network so
their values are set via your preferred
optimization method one of the most well
known examples of this idea is where -
back where - back is a very shallow
neural network is actually a two layer
neural network that learns D dimensional
embeddings for items by maximizing the
log likelihood of a word appearing in a
given context the idea is that because
semantically similar words appear in
similar context in order to model the
log-likelihood the future
representations are embedding that you
know you're going to learn are gonna
have to be similar for similar words so
in this you know artificial example you
would see that the vector representing
dog and puppy are very close together in
vector space a little bit farther away
our dog and cat and farther away dog and
flower so for those of you who haven't
played around with word Tyvek it's a
really fun tool to play with there's a
nice tutorial on how to implement where
Tyvek models and tons are flow here and
you can actually download the word to
that software online so how can we use
some of these concepts to help us and
recommendation so we can learn
embeddings for the information that we
have namely the title tokens and the key
value properties and then we can use
those embeddings as as input to a
predictive model that predicts whether
two items are likely to be purchased by
the same user all right so returning the
question of like when we should use deep
learning on sort of some high level sort
of guidelines are like when dealing with
natural language or in other domains
where you have high dimensional sparse
feature vectors you can learn embeddings
as part of an end-to-end machine
learning algorithm if you find yourself
manually doing a lot of manual feature
engineering where sort of it's just too
hard to encode all the semantics
you need a model to understand it can be
very useful to try to learn those
automatically now one caveat though is
that deep learning models tend to be
very very data hungry so you either need
to have a lot of training data in the
you know hundreds of thousands to
millions of examples or you can you know
take a pre trained model for example you
know one of the many models that are
available online that you can then
fine-tune on your own data in order to
allow the model to adapt to the
distribution of your data set so we've
had a brief introduction to some of the
concepts in deep learning and we think
that we can use some of these concepts
in building a recommender system now we
need to figure out how to actually frame
the problem of recommendations as one
that can be optimized using a deep
neural network so to do that let's take
another look at cosine distance so we
saw earlier that one way of making item
to item recommendations is to take the
cosine distance of the ratings vector
and um well sorry either as a ratings
vector or the KO port is vector between
two items and then sort according to the
cosine distance so let's take a closer
to look as to what cosine distance
actually measures so cosine similarity
specifically measures the cosine of the
angle between two vectors alright so it
rewards vectors according to you know
how many elements of those vectors match
while normalizing them by the product of
the l2 norms of the vectors now when the
vectors are binary there's actually sort
of another may be more useful way we can
think about cosine distance so the dot
product in the numerator between these
binary vectors basically rewards two
items for every time that there's a one
in the same position of those vectors
right in other words um in our case if
our you know our co purchased vectors
are the users who bought an item if
there's a one in both
that means that the same user bought
both items right and then it penalize
--is the distance according to the
square root of how many ones in the
vector right in other words how many
times each item has been purchased so
what does this mean for us so instead we
can interpret this as operations on sets
all right the vector s can be thought of
as the set of all users who bought item
s the vector R is the set of all users
who bought item R and we can take the
intersection of this two sets which
tells us how many people bought both
items s and R so the larger this number
is generally the more confident we are
that our would be a good recommendation
for s except for the fact that we
normalize so our normalization consists
of the square root of the number of
times s was purchased and R times the
square root of the number of times item
R was purchased so this measure rewards
item pairs s and R that are frequently
Co purchased by the same user but as a
penalty for s and RS that are purchased
very very often independently of each
other so if s and R are purchased
together very often then it's fine right
but if s NR are purchased together sort
of infrequently compared to how often
they're purchased individually then we
actually want to have a penalty for that
and that's what this this measure gives
us so we would like our deep learning
approach to do something similar we want
to define the objective function for our
top level trainable classifier so that
we optimize the model to achieve sort of
the same effect with its predictions
right we want it to reward pairs that
are purchased together more frequently
while penalizing those that are very
popular
so let's actually think about sort of
loss function that that we would on the
model so a very common top level
classifier used in building deep
learning classifiers is logistic
regression binary logistic regression
models predict the probability of a
binary response variable like a co
Purchase given the input features so in
our case suppose that we define our
input features as feature functions on
our seed and candidate items so from
here on out s is always going to be the
seed item and R is going to be the
recommendation candidate item let's
assume that these feature functions Phi
are actually automatically learnt
feature extractors as part of a neural
network and let's assume that it's going
to embed our items based on their titles
their properties and so on into ad
dimensional vector space then what we
would want is we want to model the event
that the same user will purchase both
items s and R while penalizing those
items that are very popular so to train
the models are that to train the
parameters of a logistic regression
model H and in an end-to-end fashion the
parameters of the entire neural network
including the future extractors and so
on we minimize the negative log
likelihood function which basically
measures by how much the distribution
estimated by our model diverges from the
observed empirical distribution of
labels that we see in our training set
so we can rewrite that loss function by
explicitly highlighting the term that
applies to positive labels and the term
that applies to negative labels like so
so this first term here models the
deviation between the the true copers
item that we observe versus what our
model predicts and then this term
represents the negative of the deviation
for the negative examples now in our
case the training data only consists of
positive examples right the only thing
that we know is the distribution of
pairs of items that were purchased by
the same user right we don't actually
have any explicit negative examples
right it's up to us to define that
distribution from which we sample our
negative examples so the question is is
can we sample our negative examples in
such a way so that we achieve the same
sort of penalty that cosine similarity
applies to popular items s and R so we
have two sorts of penalties to consider
right the first is the normalization
factor on the popularity of the seed
item s in our case we want to rank
candidates for a given seed right in
other words we have a user who just
bought item s and we want to be able to
rank recommendation candidates you know
1 through n for a given seed that square
root of s is going to be constant for
each seed right so we can actually just
treat that as a constant and not worry
about that then to sample our negative
examples we can sample proportionally to
the square root of how many times a
recommendation candidate was purchased
so what this does the fact that this has
that for every seed candidate pair in
our training data we're going to sample
that candidate item as a negative
example proportionally to how often it
is purchased independently of the seed
item right so what that does is that
basically constructs a training set
where for
echh you know positive pair s and r
we're actually going to sample square
root of r negative examples now it also
happens that this objective function is
the same as that for forward to back
it's the same it's the same objective
function that the Skip Graham with
negative sampling solves for that's not
by accident and I'm have to go to the
details during the office hours later
so to recap there are a couple things we
need to think about when devising the
deep learning based solution to solving
a problem all right you need to
understand and quantify the properties
of youright of the ideal solution to
your problem and then figure out how to
use your loss function your your
sampling strategies for your training
data and even your neural network
architecture even though we didn't go
into that here to achieve those same
properties cool so so far we've
discussed the objective function we're
optimizing and how we devised the
sampling strategy but we actually
haven't talked much about deep learning
yet so deep learning models can be very
time consuming both to train and to use
for inference so the design of any deep
learning architecture ought to take
runtime performance constraints into
account as well as the quality of the
model predictions so just to give you a
taste of this let's let's consider the
scale of the problem that we actually
have to solve at eBay so on average we
have around 4 million new items listed
every single day now suppose that for
each item we have a recall set of 1
million candidates so let's assume that
we just have some other system that for
a given seed item gives us a list of
candidates to rank so what this means is
that on a daily basis our network is
going to need to evaluate 4 times 10 to
the 12 item pairs which is a lot since
there are some 86,000 seconds every day
that means we need to evaluate pairs at
the rate of
about 46 million pairs per second so we
want to build our models such that it
would require the least possible amount
of hardware to run and reach our
performance target so broadly speaking
there are two ways we can achieve the
desired rate all right we can maximize
how many item pairs we process at the
same time and we can minimize how much
time it takes to evaluate a single pair
we can achieve these goals in a number
of ways all right first we can scale
horizontally across machines all items
on ebay belong to a category and the way
that we select the set of recommendation
candidate free each seed item depends
both on the category of the seed item
and the category of the candidates we
can shard the categories horizontally
meaning hat meaning that each machine is
responsible for computing the ranking
for items within a set of categories we
can also try to maximize parallelism
within the model so by using specialized
hardware like a GPU that has many more
processing units than a CPU within the
device on the GPU card we can actually
execute the model in parallel on
multiple item pairs because the
evaluation of each item pair is
independent of one another we can also
try to make sure that the different
components in the model can be run
independently of each other right so we
can paralyze the application of sort of
the independent parameters of the neural
network on a single item pair and then
finally we can use highly tuned GPU code
in the form of on different CUDA
libraries to ensure that each
mathematical operator we apply in the
execution of our model is as fast as
possible
so let's now go into how we can design
our model to adhere to these principles
so recall that you know we want to model
this probability that a seed item and a
candidate item are both purchased by the
same user conditioned on the features of
the seed and candidate items right so
what that means that we can decompose
our network into three sub networks
broadly alright we have five function
that operates on the seed item in order
to construct the the feature
representation of that item we have the
five function that operates on the
candidate item and then we have the
top-level classifier that uses those two
as input in order to make its prediction
so let's first talk about the design of
our feature extractor layers so the
input for the feature extractor for a
given seat for a given item is going to
be the tokens in the title the key value
properties and the category so we're
going to start by embedding each of the
title tokens property parent category
into a d-dimensional dictionary one way
to think about this dictionary is that
it's just a matrix that has a row for
each token in the vocabulary and then -
you can either index you know you can
either index into it or you can take the
product of the one-hot representation of
a token and that matrix in order to
retrieve that the embedding for that for
that token and these you know like we
said before these are just parameters
like other parameters in the model that
we optimize end to end we then apply a
pooling layer and the idea here is that
we want to combine the information
present in all the title token
embeddings in order to construct a
representation of the title we want to
combine the information of the key value
properties to construct a representation
of the properties and we have the
category although in general there's
only one category for an item so
whatever we put in here will basically
be a null
now there are a lot of different ways to
pool vectors together there are a lot of
different techniques that have been
written about you have things like max
pooling on you can do something fancy
and have a convolutional neural network
or recurrent neural network to take into
account things like you know the
position of tokens we've gone with
something much simpler which is mean
pooling and what mean pooling does is it
basically just takes an element-wise
average of the embedding vectors and
produces ad dimensional vector right so
if we have a title of 5 tokens we
basically just average those 5 vectors
together to provide a D dimensional
vector so we're going to do this for the
three sets of data that we have the type
the title the properties and the
category resulting in 3d dimensional
vectors we then concatenate the vectors
together to construct an item represent
representation of dimensionality three
times B we then add a nonlinear
activation function so nonlinear
activation functions are really really
important in when when building neural
networks the idea of the non-linearity
is to project the results of linear
operations like the ones that we did
down here
into a non linear space where what that
allows us to do is allows the model to
learn parameters such that as a result
of the not the nonlinear activation the
data the the resulting vectors are going
to be linearly separable finally we add
a hidden layer that acts to combine the
information in the title vector the
property vector and the category vector
into a single representation these
hidden layers basically just involve a
matrix multiplication where the hidden
layer has a matrix of dimensionality
whatever the size of the input is by the
size of the output and then when you
multiply the input vector by the matrix
you get a vector that is that's the size
of the output dimension
and then we put that through another
non-linearity which gives us our item
representation so to construct the
end-to-end Network we're going to apply
this architecture for the for the item
embeddings to both the seat item and the
recommendation candidate so in our case
these two sub networks have their own
sets of parameters so unlike in Siamese
networks which have shared parameters we
actually don't share parameters between
these two sub networks sort of the
reason for this is a bit complex but
basically what we want to do is we want
to ensure a symmetry in our predictions
all right the we want we want to make
sure that we give different problems
different outputs for someone who bought
a seed item s and then a candidate item
R versus someone who first bought R and
then s so these that the inputs of these
two feature extractors goes to our top
level classifier which is just a simple
two layer neural network which consists
of a fully connected hidden layer and an
output layer that's just a sigmoid
function so the sigmoid function
basically takes a scalar value and
projected into space 0 1 thereby forming
a probability
so let's actually point out where we can
take advantage of parallelism and
carefully tuned CUDA libraries here so
each token embedding can be constructed
in parallel the mean pooling of the
title tokens the the attribute tokens or
the property tokens and the category can
be independent each other and then the
way that the there's a CUDA library
called KU blas which is an
implementation of the Blas API to run on
GPUs is very highly tuned and it can
exploit parallel computation when doing
matrix multiplications for the fully
connected hidden layers
so finally the last thing to point out
in terms of you know production izing
this is that there is actually some
redundancy here alright so you could in
principle run every seed candidate pair
through this network but that would
actually be highly redundant right
because you would be computing the same
feature extractor sub-networks over and
over again for the same items right you
know if we have to evaluate 1 million
candidates for a single seed it doesn't
make sense just keep recomputing the
seed representation over and over again
so in fact when we bring this to
production we're actually our
implementation actually decomposes this
network and runs the components
separately for each seed item we're
going to run the seed feature extractor
for every candidate we're going to run
the candidate extractor and finally
we're going to construct the Cartesian
product of the two sets of feature
vectors to serve as input to the top
level classifier so briefly briefly
let's see what sort of performance gains
we can get from this so on a single GPU
we can construct the seed and candidate
representations for about 40,000 items
per second in practice we're going to
cache the learn'd embeddings for the
candidate items in the database so that
we only need to run the feature
extractor on that day's newly listed
items so those 4 million items this
means that we can construct the item of
embeddings in around 2 minutes now the
expensive part of the computation is in
the top level classifier which can
process about 900 thousand item pairs
per second on a single GPU so in one day
on a single GPU we can evaluate around 7
times 10 to the 9 pairs of items now
given that we said we have 4 times 9 to
12 pairs of items that we need to
evaluate each day if we then distribute
those among 50 GPUs we'll be able to hit
that target cool so to sum up in order
for the model to be efficient in
production some sort of takeaways are
you want to design your network to
maximize parallelism in actually
applying the network you want to
minimize your redundancy and you really
need to think about accounting for every
millisecond of computation
that your network will will act on so
finally we're going to talk about the
right way to evaluate your model for the
task that you're solving for so
generally speaking the complexity of
deploying deep learning models to
production means that there can be a
fairly high cost to evaluating a model
online so given the number of choices
you have when designing deep learning
models or really any machine learning
models right in terms of the hyper
parameters that you can choose in terms
of you know things like learning rate
and in our case you know dimensionality
of different hidden layers it's really
important to understand quickly when a
model does not work well so the choice
is the valuation measure is absolutely
critical when developing deep learning
models so we said that we're building
the classifier right so there's a few
standard evaluation measures that you
could use right you have the precision
recall curve and then you have the
training error and loss curves that you
get when your model is training and
those can be really useful for making
sure that your model is training as you
expect right that you don't suffer from
problems like the exploding or vanishing
gradient problems or that your learning
rate and decay rate are working well so
you know the first couple iterations of
our models failed and we were able to
detect that by just by noticing that the
error was plateauing really really early
now while these measures are useful to
check that your training algorithm works
it's not necessarily useful for
understanding how the model is going to
perform once you apply it to a
production system
all right so in our case we actually
care about ranking candidates for a seed
item so we need to design a ranking
measure that would allow us to UM to
evaluate this
so suppose so what we're going to do is
we're going to build a held out
validation set of let's say 200 seat
items bought by users what we're going
to do then is we're going to select
trucco purchase item for each seed we're
then going to randomly sample 200
thousand random items to serve as a
recall set we then run the
all the pears all the item pears for all
of the users and then for each seed
we're going to figure out where in that
ranked list does the trucco purchase
live right the closer it is to the top
the more confidence we can have that the
model is um you know predicting
something meaningful so once we actually
construct this validation set there are
very there are several ways to evaluate
the ranking right we have their standard
ranking functions like mean average
precision discounted cumulative gain and
mean reciprocal rank but for our problem
they don't actually quite fit the bill
because they either assume having
different degrees of relevance or having
multiple sort of relevant results in a
ranked list in our case we only have one
relevant result in the rank list so
instead we actually found it really
useful to consider an average rank
across the 200 CDI tons by averaging
over the position of the trucco purchase
in the rank list but instead of using
the mean which is highly sensitive to
outliers we decided to evaluate our
models using the medium having a median
rank of 2 for example means that 50% of
our predictions have are in the top two
slots right which is very good so it's
also really easy to interpret that
result right because then you can go to
your business partners and say hey look
for 50% of recommendations the top the
thing that the user will end up buying
on average in the top two slots um
especially because our recall set is so
large and we have a very long tail when
using the mean is going to be much
harder to actually interpret those
results and then finally once you do
bring your model to production the way
to test on real you know the best way to
evaluate it on is on real data so in our
case we have to use both crowdsource
human judgment evaluations in terms of
relevance as well as a/b tests cool so
to sum up a deep learning can be a very
effective tool in solving a lot of
different data science problems in
production but it's really important to
understand how and when to apply it and
how to experiment with and evaluate
models quickly to allow you to fail fast
so I hope this talk has helped eliminate
some of these issues thank you
[Applause]
great mic on
Thank You Danielle that was a great talk
while Laura gets set up we probably have
time for one question
hi I was wondering about the last part
evaluating the D planning method so
let's say you're looking at the
precision recall curve and it's not what
you expected how do you then go and
figure out which part of your pipeline
is what we should be working on yeah
that's a really good question um we have
yet to figure out sort of like a set of
rules for that mostly at least in my
experience it's just true it's just to
just to try to understand the problem
that we're trying to solve and to
understand the distribution of data if
you understand sort of if you can come
up with some hypotheses as to what the
neural network is doing you can then
just test by swapping out different
components of the neural network by you
know trying to understand like how the
different parameters are interacting
with each other and going from there